I am Carol Leifer here and this is two
minute papers where I explain awesome
research in simple words first of all I
am very happy to see that you like the
series also thanks for sharing it on the
social media sites and please keep them
coming this episode is going to be about
artificial neural networks I will
quickly explain what the huge deep
learning rage is all about this graph
depicts a neural network that we build
and simulate on a computer it is a very
crude approximation of the human brain
the leftmost layer denotes inputs which
can be for instance the pixels of an
input image the rightmost layer is the
output which can be for instance a
decision whether the image depicts a
horse or not after we have given many
inputs to the neural network in its
hidden layers it will learn to figure
out a way to recognize different classes
of inputs such as horses people or
school buses what is really surprising
is that it's quite faithful to the way
the brain does represent objects on a
lower level it has a very similar edge
detector and it also works for audio
here you can find the difference between
the neurons in the hearing system of a
cat versus a simulated neural network on
the same audio signals I mean come on
this is amazing
what is the deep learning part all about
well it means that our neural network
has multiple hidden layers on top of
each other the first layer for an image
consists of edges and as we go up the
combination of edges gives us object
parts a combination of object parts
shared object models and so on this kind
of hierarchy provides us very powerful
capabilities for instance in this
traffic sign recognition contest the
second place was taken by humans but
what's more interesting is that the
first place was not taken by humans it
was taken by a neural network algorithm
think about that and if you find these
topics interesting you feel you would
like to hear about the newest research
discoveries in an understandable way
please become a fellow scholar and hit
that subscribe button and for now thanks
for watching and I'll see you next time